KEVIN: Let's go find
Look at that.
That's like a ladder statue.
ROLI: Ladder art.
On the right.
What is that?
KEVIN: It's a Rambler.
Yeah, that one, I
think we've seen.
[music playing]
That's kinda cool.
MAN: It has to be,
like, 50, right?
Like, mid 50s.
KEVIN: Yeah, mid 50s.
Well, let's go check it out.
[music playing]
Hey, it has plates on it.
Maybe the truck drives.
You never know.
KEVIN: You never know.
It's in pretty good
shape though, I think.
[knocking]
How you doing?
ROLI: How you doing, man.
I'm Kevin and this is Roli.
We were just looking
at that truck.
And see if it's for sale.
Wow.
Did you say 40?
BOTH: 40,000?
Wow.
Roli and I are looking at
this awesome 1956 Ford truck.
It's got a steep price tag,
but it might be worth it
if it's in great shape.
Yeah?
- Ford tractor?
Nice.
NARRATOR: The 1956 Ford F 100
trucks are truly one of a kind.
That year, the body style
got some great upgrades,
including a new grill and
a wrap around windshield.
The interior also saw some
great safety upgrades,
like seat belts and the new
Lifeguard steering wheel,
designed to put more
space between the driver
and the dash.
But this body style was
only produced for one year,
making these trucks
extremely hard to find.
I don't know if I
can open this thing.
Let's see if I can get it.
Why don't you try
it right there.
This thing's real heavy.
There you go.
There it is.
MAN: Look at that tractor motor.
ROLI: Straight six
tractor engine.
Originally it's a V8.
MAN: It was.
ROLI: It says it on there.
MAN: It was a V8.
My grandfather blew it
up in his construction
business driving up
to his mining claims
up in the mountains.
ROLI: But then this
one gave him power.
MAN: Well, this thing
climbs like a mountain goat.
KEVIN: Yeah.
MAN: This one out climbs the V8.
It's just not as fast.
But here's the important thing.
You might want to
take come check
it out on this side over here.
We're not quite
sure of the stories,
but that's something that--
ROLI: That looks like a bullet.
MAN: Yeah.
ROLI: It looks like someone
was aiming the driver.
MAN: Somebody was
shooting at grandpa.
Yeah.
MAN: He had a lot
of enemies and he
took care of a lot of people.
But this is strong.
Dad's looking to sell it.
ROLI: It's solid.
MAN: It is solid and it doesn't
have any rust that I can tell.
I wouldn't lower it.
I wouldn't do anything
and putting crazy on it.
I would just paint it.
ROLI: Or just put
clear coat on it.
Actually you could
just clear coat it.
MAN: Yeah, I love
this look, myself.
ROLI: Yeah.
KEVIN: You know, I'm a
just take quick pick.
What was your name?
My name's Loren.
KEVIN: Thanks again, Loren.
We appreciate your
time, brother.
ROLI: Nice to meet you.
KEVIN: Man, this truck
has a really cool history.
And I know it's very
special to the family.
And I think that's why Loren's
dad has it priced so high.
But at $40,000, I don't know
how the shop can make a profit.
Danny would want
to keep this one.
I think Roli and I will just
keep this one on the down low.
That's the first time I see
a bullet hole on a vehicle.
I kind of like it, actually.